- And then once this green cell
the linker cell reaches
the tail of the animal,
it dies there
and it has to die there,
because if it doesn't die,
it kind of clogs this connection
that the gonad makes with the cloacal
which allows the sperm
of the worm to release.
So, essentially it will result
in the animal being
and fertile and sterile
so, essentially this is the second big job
of this linker of green
linker cell that it has to die
and the way it dies,
it's really interesting
and probably, you know, you look
you'll read the prime or the preview,
the review article
and there's a lot of
complicated information
but I hope you got from it
that there are different
types of cell death
and there was a little section
on linker cell death there,
we will not go into all the details
but, I just kind, I just wanted to share
with you one observation
that really struck me
when I started to study this,
so, when the cell
migrates in the young worm
it has a very nice and round nucleus,
so, it's a migrating linker cell here
but when it starts to die
what we see is that this
nucleus becomes quite deformed
and we call it nuclear deformation,
and so I was very curious to understand
how this deformation happened
from this nice and round nucleus,
like in all the normal cells
to this very deformed nucleus
and why is that important?
Actually, this different
kind of nucleus is observed
in all of the aggressive cancer types
and the more aggressive the cancer is
the more the deformed the nucleus.
Also it's observed in some of
the neurodegenerative diseases
and the aging diseases
and the diseases of the
heart is cardiomyopathy is
in the muscular dystrophy
so, it seems to be relevant
to many, many different conditions
and I'm just really, really
interested to understand
how does this happen
and today with you people
tackle this first question
to understand
to sort of form an observation about this
and so what I wanted to do
is to look in live animals
and look specifically at the nucleus,
using some of the cell biology tools,
to see, how this change happens
and when step back for a second
I will just to show you a schematic
of the nucleus structure.
So, this is the whole cell that you have
and this is the nucleus inside,
then you have a DNA in here,
so, the nucleus has a double membrane
and you call it the nuclear envelope
and then there is this Lamina in the blue
which is composed of Lamin protein
and essentially what I
decided to do is to look
at this Lamin protein,
because it will allow me to
see how the nucleus looks
and how do we do with that?
So, that's the due, thanks
to this awesome technology
of the green fluorescent
protein called GFP
this protein was discovered in jellyfish
and there was actually a Nobel
prize was awarded in 2008
in chemistry to three
scientists who worked with us
and they saw that this protein
emits green light
when you shine UV light on it
and they were able to put it
attach it to other proteins and cells,
it's kinda like a piggyback
and so you can follow other proteins
and see what they do in
the cell or in the animal.
So here, what I have is
I have my Lamin protein
and I have the GFP attached to it
so, by looking at the GFP,
it's almost like I'm looking at Lamin
and I will know where Lamin is
because Lamin is invisible normally.
So, now when you look at your nucleus,
so each molecule Lamin
in the nucleus now will
have this little tag of GFP
and all of them will be fluorescing
and when I put them under
the fluorescing microscope
and so you will see it, the light shining
you will be able to see
it, this nuclear shade.
Okay, so I think I have
to quickly move now to
my first microscopy room
I will walk you through the lab,
so come along with me
we will just see a little bit and
I have to put on my mask
because now I'm entering the space
where other people are working.
So, this is (indistinct)
I will show you guys
some of the lab as we walk through it
but,
we have these incubators,
we brought the (indistinct)
and now we will enter the microscope room.
So, it's usually dark in here
I will shut off the lights
and what I will do is
When you look at the worms channel now
I will turn on the fluorescence
you will be able to see
something happening.
So, do you all see it? Put a thumbs up
If you see it, that the
worms are fluorescing
(Olya laughs)
you see this tiny little
green spots? essentially
we see all of these nuclei
and all of the cells of the animal.
So just, and it's quite amazing
that we can see it live here
and this is great that we can see it live.
However, this is not the
good enough resolution
and we want to look at
the single cell, right
the linker cell and what
happens to it nucleus,
so, we really have to go
to really, really zoom in
and to do that, we will transfer to a more
complex microscope,
more complex fluorescent
microscope to see that.
So, I'm just gonna just
bear with me for a seconds,
just need to remove my phone, my computer,
I'm gonna walk to a different
microscopy room now,
(indistinct) so you can
see the lab a little bit.
They are all working in
masks, socially distanced.
Now, this is a much bigger microscope
it has a computer connected to it
so we'll be able to see images on this,
just give me a second to connect my phone
I have this adapter that connects
to my phone and goes into the microscope
hope all of you can see this,
we turn on the lights.
Okay, there we go
so, now essentially to be able to
see the animals so close by
you see that they are
not moving here, right,
I put them on these glass slides
and I put a cover slip on top of them
and I added a drop of anesthesia to them
so they are essentially sleeping
and they stopped moving
because when I want to take
a picture of the single cell
I really can't have them move
because then my picture will
not come up really well.
So, I need them to stop moving and sleep
and that's how I can
take a picture of them.
They can be revived
after this if necessary
but usually we don't provide them
because we just grow so many of them
and we just can always get more.
- [Teacher] Oh yeah, if they
die, will they stop fluorescing
A student is asking.
- Actually all the animals Flores more
they have the green autofluorescence
and sometimes you can see a dead animal
that has this autofluorescence to it
and also because they
eat bacteria and their
intestine is like a
huge part of their body
sometimes you can see a
lot of extra fluorescence
coming from there.
I was just going to say that,
please interrupt me with questions.
I forgot to put this, to
say this in the beginning
but I'm happy to answer at any point.
Yeah, so here essentially, we
see a closeup of the animal
and
you guys can see,
unfortunately, I can't really
show you with anything,
but you can see the outline of an animal
right in the middle of the animal,
we have a tail
and this is where the dye
in linker cell will be,
so know, let us take a picture
let me show you how we do it.
So, there we have a computer,
we have special software
where we have to select different channels
that we want to do
probably a little hard to see
Now, I have to unfortunately remove
the cell therapy because
now all the light goes
to the objective and
goes down to the slide
and the output goes to my phone,
however, in order to take the picture
I need to direct the output
to the camera that is up here
so to do that, I need to switch
so you won't see the worms
on your screen anymore
but we will take a picture
you can probably hear
the noise a little bit
this is our picture.
So, I don't know how well
you can see it from here
but let's remove some filter,
so, when green you can
see many green spots
so these are all the
nuclei and all the cells
and then you can see this strand signal.
So, actually this GFP
protein can be modified
to emit different colors.
So, now it will be called
red fluorescent protein,
yellow fluorescent
protein and other kinds,
so here, what I have,
I have a special red fluorescent protein
that only marks the linker cell,
so, you can see it here
I know where the linker
cell is and by doing so
I will know which nucleus
belongs to the linker cell.
So, I can all relapse and I can see, okay
here's the nucleus that
is inside this cell
and when I remove the cell,
I can see the nucleus inside
and so essentially after this,
I guess this is not even
the most complicated
Microscope that I use,
but this is the only,
the best one I can
demonstrate to you in the lab
in this class,
I actually have to go,
we have this imaging facility
that has probably 20 to 30 different
very expensive microscopes
and I'm trying from some
of them to take images
so, I will show you the
output of those damages,
I will share my presentation
and just show you a couple
of very short videos
of what happens
just give me a second please,
and share my screen with you.
Okay, can people see my screen?
Okay.
Okay, so essentially this is from this
light field microscope
and this allows me to
look at the sounds in 3D
and I make this a tiny
bit, these short videos
so, what you have here
is you have the animal
in which the linker cell is migrating,
it's marked in red as you have just seen
and all of the nuclei and
other cells are marked in green
so when I play this video
you can see in 3D that this is the nuclear
of the linker cell
and you can see the
other nuclei around that
and by looking at this, you
can immediately tell me,
there's more green signal in the cell
and I will say, yes, I agree with you
and this is already an
interesting observation.
So, essentially as scientists,
what we do and what I will do
with this is I will
take many many pictures
like 50 to a hundred pictures of worms
of these linker cells
and I will look at these images
and try to find the trend
and try to find some observation,
what do I see?
What is different
in the linker cell
compared to other cells?
What is different in this migrating cell
versus when the cell starts to die
and here I have one video
of the cell that starts to,
that is dying.
So, you can see the cell here the nucleus
and actually by these images, I observed
that this lamin forms this thick wall
in the dying cells
and as of now I don't really know
what's the significance of this
but this is the observation that I made
and now, as scientists
we have to build different
hypotheses to try to answer
why do you think this happens?
We might want to try to prepare the slime
and then the linker cell
and see if things go
differently. If the cell can not
survive or if it dies
faster and things like that.
So, yeah this is basically
I guess the end of my demonstration
and I would be happy to
take questions from you.
I can go back to the,
I can go back to the room
where I can uncover my face again.
- So, while she's walking back
y'all can think of your questions,
feel free to raise your hand
and unmute yourselves
or feel free to ask questions in the chat.
- Yeah, sorry I'm here,
I just.
(both speaking)
(both laughing)
Everybody froze (indistinct)
but hopefully you guys all
had the chance to think
of some questions that you want to ask me
and we can have a bit of a Q
and A before this class ends
- So there are questions on
how they make this technology,
I guess they're talking
about like the microscopes
- You're talking about the microscopes
or are you talking about
have you engineered the
proteins that attacked
with this fluorescent
tag with this GFP tag?
- Evan, would you like to clarify?
- [Evan] Well, like in general,
because like the quality
of like the things we got
shown were like really
good and I had not seen
before, to be honest,
So I'm just wondering like,
how they even like managed to do this.
- Well, the microscopes are
just getting better and better
(laughs)
and
yeah, so I mean, yeah, rarely at the,
I guess there are two
technologies that are used here
one that I described the, this GFP tagging
right? So that is actually
done by, you can now with the
I don't know if you guys have
heard this CRISPR technology
for genome engineering,
so you can put
you can take the sequence of this GFP tag
and attach it to the sequence
of your favorite protein
your favorite gene,
and you will essentially make it.
So this is one technology,
the other technology is microscopy
and there are so many
different microscopes
that you can use for this,
I showed you today
the camera compound with
which we took a picture,
I showed you the videos that I took
with the light field microscopes,
so it takes many, many tiny sections
that are separated from each other
and then I use the software
that puts it all together
and so at the end, you get this output
of a 3D video that you can,
you know, that you can see
you can go into individual
slices and you can take a look,
there are other microscopes
that are called confocal,
you know, I'm not a microscope specialist
but I showed you a little
bit about have, you know,
you have your slide on there
and how the light goes through,
essentially the technology is
that you shine the lights and
the fluorescent microscope
and your fluorescent
protein emits the light back
that has done the tag to
it, and you can see it
and of course the better
resolution cameras
we have now the better pictures you have,
so, the cameras are constantly improving
and this was also another reason why
we can get better and better picture.
- There is a question before
about the magnification that you used
for the first microscope
- The first microscope, it was only a
two times X magnification,
so, you can, when you look at the worms
on the plates against some light,
you will see tiny animals
but when you want to see a little bit
but usually when they want to
see a bit better, you know,
use 1.6 or 2X magnification
to look at the live animals
but then when you want to images
usually at least 40X we look at 40X
We took a picture, but 40X magnification
and I also do a 63X
and you can do a 100X
to really see clearly.
- Can you elaborate on why the
linker cells glow brighter?
- Well, that's a kind of a
very general tag that we use
and it's a bit, it's a
kind of tool just to know
where that linker cell is,
the worm is transparent
so we can actually see it
without the fluorescence
but it's better to have
the fluorescent tag
it depends on what kind of tag we use,
some of them are brighter
and some of them are dimmer,
I have different kinds of tags
for the linker cell
and I have many of the engineered
worm strains, that will
glow different colors
so I have linker cells that
can be very, very dark red
the red one that you saw
I have the ones that can be green
and so I can mix and match them
but the proteins that I want to see
because sometimes my proteins
I tagged with the red
fluorescent proteins,
so then I need to take green linker cell.
Yeah
- And then there's a question on
how do they differ between
the linker cell and-
Oh, nevermind.
They said that answered their question.
(laughs)
Okay.
I guess from your observation
for when you got like the
grouping of all the GFP cells
do you have any like hypothesis
as to why that's happening?
- Well when I look, I definitely see
that in the linker cell there's
a stronger green GFP signal
as you saw from the picture
that we took together,
sorry, from the picture
that I showed you at the end
and I think it's probably
it's a property of the migrating cells
they have to be a bit more flexible
and be able to mold because they move
through the other tissues
and cells and the worms,
so the lamin allows the
nucleus to be a little
bit more flexible,
but then once the cell is dying
and you form this kind of patch
on one side of the cell
that I also observed
in like very old worms
so in their styles, this happens as well.
It happens in this aging
disease called progeria
I don't know if you
guys heard about it, but
it's a disease when children
become old really, really fast.
So, the same thing happens in there
and what I'm trying to understand now is
why does it happen and
what genes control this,
but I have many different hypotheses
that I'm testing right now
and maybe in the future
I will be able to tell you
about my discovery of this.
- Is there a definite way
to measure fluorescence?
- Yes, there is a way
to measure fluorescence,
but in my hands I think
you have to be careful
about measuring fluorescence,
the amount of fluorescence,
you will need to have some kind
of other tag in your worm,
some other fluorescent tag
that you will know should
be something constant
that should not change
from worm to worm too much
this will be kinda like
your background level
and if you want to measure any differences
in what you're looking for,
you will be comparing that
to this kind of background level, to see
that the variation doesn't come,
just because you're looking
at different animals,
they have slightly different age
may be on different slides
there is a different fluorescence
the way that you prepare the slides
so for me, I prefer not to
measure fluorescence directly,
I prefer to, you know, when
I look at these structures
and I see this one GFP
blob, I will say, Oh
in this cell, I will,
I observe this one blob
and I will see, do I have any
cells that have two blobs?
So, then I will count the cells.
I have 10 cells with one blob
and I have two cells with two blobs
and this is the kinda
quantification I prefer to do myself
but people do measure fluorescence
you just have to be more
careful how you do it.
So you don't introduce any
error into your quantification.
- Yeah, so it's measured relatively rather
than on a universal scale
that's what they call them
And what does a normal
day in the lab look like?
- Well, right now I,
my main responsibility
and the lab is really just research
and so when I get in, I usually have
different times booked
on different microscopes
so we have this booking system
so all members of the lab can plan ahead
and they will approximate
how much time they will need
on all the microscopes
and so we have this lab, Google calendar
for different microscopes,
and usually I will
I also make this genetic crosses
between different animals
so I need to use this small
microscopes that I showed you
in the beginning
to determine to, you know,
determine what's the outcome of the cross
I usually take images and essentially
all day is really filled
with experiments now
and, you know,
sometimes you need to
make a conscious decision
and the time that's, I
need to go and get water
I need the break to eat
because sometimes you're just so carried
by the experiment that you
forget to do those things
and it also depends on
how your experiments are.
Are they really time sensitive?
You know, do you have to put on a timer
and you will have some kinda
chemical reaction running
and you really have to stop it in time
and those experiments tend to be a little
but more stressful,
or for example, when I
need to revive the worm
I take back that slide
and I have to be very, very gentle
and gently, pick it off from that slide
and put it on the bacteria, and wait
and hope that it will come
back to life, essentially.
Yeah, so this is kind of
a typical day in the lab
and scientists have really
not normal working days
It all depends on the
experiment that we are doing,
so Monday, you might have
experiments until midnight.
You know, if you plan like that some day
you might have half a day of experiments,
so it really is depends on what you do
and usually how you
schedule your experiments
and I like this flexibility a lot
that I can determine what I do everyday.
- Same, well, not now anymore.
So where was I
so going back to the, the lamin blob
where would you start tackling
the significance of it?
- Well, so what I'm doing
now is I have this collection
of different genetic mutants
of the genes that we know
that somehow impact the
death of the linker cells
so we do know that the
death of the linker cell
is programmed, which means that
you know, there is a
kind of program of genes
you know, one gene turns on
the next gene, the next gene
the next gene that leads to
the death of the linker cell
and we know a lot of these
genes that are involved in this.
So I'm using some of these mutant worms
in which the linker cells
will abnormally survive
they will not die,
they will normally
survive and I want to look
at what happens to lamin and dwarf cells.
So that's one angle to what I'm doing,
another thing that I'm doing
is I want to essentially decrease
the amount of lamin in the linker cell
and they have this tool where
I can do it specifically on me
and the linker cell and it's called RNAi
technology
and it's very useful in the C elegans,
when you want to decrease some gene
you just feed them the bacteria,
that codes for these short sequences
that will match your gene of interest
and these short sequences will interfere
with your genome interest
and essentially you will have a decrease
of your gene of interest
and so I'm curious to see
if I decrease lamin in the linker cells
if that has an impact, if not the cells,
will not the die or die,
or, you know, what will happen to them.
Yeah, so these are a couple
of directions I'm pursuing.
- So, I know the period is ending,
so for those who have to
go I think your teacher
gave you permission to leave for those who
want to stay along we can continue
answering questions. Thank you all.
that was amazing.
(both laughing)
I was also fascinated by it.
There was
are they more applications
to the research you do other
than cancer and progeria research?
- Yeah, as I said
neurodegenerative disorders
actually even know one of the genes that
directs linker cell death is very similar
to the gene found in
humans that is implicated
and these neurodegenerative disorders
like Huntington disease and
other diseases like that,
so it's a very direct
and exciting link that's we have
overall
it's also similar to aging cells,
so, aging overall these
nuclear changes happen,
essentially, in aging
and why do they happen?
We don't really know.
Yeah, so I would say cancer
and neurodegeneration, cardio myopathy
so these are different defects
of the heart that leads
to very early heart attacks
like in your twenties
and your thirties
muscular dystrophy is where
your muscles just weather a way
all of these kinds of diseases,
so it's, I think it's a quite
light spectrum of diseases
and one of the things
I'm trying to determine, you know,
which direction to go with my research
or should I do a little bit of
that connects to different diseases?
- And what got you into
wanting to study cell death
over other aspects of cell bio?
- This, kind of came a
little bit from my PHD
my PHD was in this process
called DNA methylation
so when you have your
DNA and on the cytosines
you are able to add the methyl group
and for example, a big part
of our DNA that used to
be called junk DNA has this
methylation mark on it.
Also a huge part of our DNA
is composed of viral DNA
or viruses that in fact,
that us through, you know
through all the ages
and could incorporate
that DNA into our DNA
this was a mechanism for the
cell to tag the spiral DNA,
so it does not,
so the cell knows this is not my DNA.
I can not touch this DNA and
the right to silence this DNA
and there was just some
interesting observation that when
in these cells that are
deficient for DNA methylation
that they were dying in a wired way
and not the right that we know,
but the different kind of way
and also some of it that was connected
to different neuropathy diseases
and just kind of through this
I was curious to understand
what happens with cell death
and I might go back to
these deficient methylation
cells to see what happens there.
But I also really wanted, in my PHD
I worked for cells that grow in culture
and I really wanted to
look at the actual organism
I did work with mice
a little bit in my PHD
but I didn't enjoy it so much,
A lot of people do it, but to
me, it was a bit sensitive.
They were cute and it
was hard to kill them.
Doing dissections was, was fine
but to kill them was very hard for me.
So, I just wanted to work for the
some smaller organism that
I could do research in
and I think that C elegans
worms are a beautiful model
and easy to work with
and just being able to see the cell live
and being able to see
what happens to it live.
It's quite amazing.
So, we can really observe
this physiological
process that unfolds
and it's probably a little
bit less complicated
than it is in mice or us,
so once we figured that out, I want to,
I do want to take it to mice in the future
when I have my own lab
and, but then people
will be working for me
and they can work
with mice and figure out
what happens in mice.
- it's funny 'cause the session before
they preferred mice over monkey
then you prefer worms over mice,
so it's like organisms that you work with
and then we'll just do one last question
and then we'll let everyone go.
So, now with Corona virus
do you have anyone that's
helping or working with you?
- Actually, we are not
allowed to have new people
like new volunteers.
I did have a high school
student who worked
with me last year and
I'm trying to hear back
what are the rules of the university
if she can even come back to campus,
essentially right now
some of the undergraduates
who already had access to campus
and are volunteering are able to come back
but new people are not allowed.
That's why you guys
we are doing this
virtual sessions with you
otherwise you would be coming here.
Yeah, so unfortunately because of that,
so I, yes, I can't
I don't have anybody
working with me right now,
I would love to in the
future, after this all ends.
- Awesome, so thank you again,
I don't know if there
are any last questions
for those who are hanging out,
if not we can dismiss it and
hopefully we'll see you all
in some of our other programs.
So, just a reminder for the SSIP program
if y'all are interested
those applications are open
and they close on December.
Awesome.
- Thank you so much, guys,
have a great day.
- Bye.